the abalene Paradox the abalene Paradox
is a situation in which a group makes a
decision that is contrary to the desires
of that group's members because each
member assumes the others approve of it
it explains how a number of accurate
individuals can become idiots when they
get together so think Emperor new
clothes an acquaintance invites you to
his wedding despite not wanting you
there because he thinks you want to
attend you attend despite not wanting to
because you think he wants you there
rational people that I knew in private
held quite balanced beliefs or quite
normal beliefs seem to change an awful
lot when they got into a group and not
just in a performative way but that
their actual ethics seemed to adjust
like they were a different person not
only in presentation but in content too
in substance as well if you're somebody
that sits anywhere outside of the
absolute cookie cutter extremist on both
sides ideology you are going to be
observed as an unreliable Ally by the
people that are further out to the right
or the left than you because they are by
definition more predictable